today a cdc advisory panel is meeting to
vote on recommendations about
who will get the vaccines first once
they're approved by the fda
cbs news medical contributor that's dr
david agus joins us now to discuss that
david always good to see you you know
when you hear 20 million you that sounds
like a big number
but it's not a big number when you
consider how many people need the
vaccine
so who gets it first we keep hearing the
elderly or other vulnerable
or front-line workers is it an either or
situation do you have to choose between
the two groups
well we're going to see the end of today
a recommendation by this immunization
practice committee the cdc and you've
got about 21 million health care workers
in the united states
you've got about three million long-term
care or nursing home residents in the
united states
and you've got about 20 million doses
initially
and so you know to me you have to put
even though it's myself you have to put
people at the front line who are risking
their life to help others
and you have to vaccinate them to enable
to care for others
and then when you look at the percentage
of deaths in long-term care
and nursing homes it is dramatically
high 40 percent of deaths in the country
are those individuals
so they are very at risk those two
populations i think will be first
and then we're talking about elderly
other frontline workers
you know people with medical issues and
disabilities but those put the numbers
in the hundreds of millions
who are going to require over 100
million people with medical issues and
elderly in this country
so it's going to be difficult that
second one but we need to get the
vaccine out and hopefully it will happen
soon yeah it looks like we're going to
have a choice david between two vaccines
which one
are you recommending to the people that
you care about
well to me whatever vaccine you can get
first
you take there's you don't think one is
better than the other you don't think
one is better than the other no
no no and i mean they're going to be
three candidates
astrazeneca oxford there's going to be
modern and there's going to be fizer
each one of them have merits
each one of them 100 have been able to
block hospitalization and block people
from being very sick with the virus
and that is the goal of the vaccine each
one of them achieved that so depending
on where you live
and what is distributed and you know
what class you fall into there may be
one two or three being offered at that
moment
but i would take whatever you can get
right now i like all three of them which
is an amazing thing to say
yeah yeah listen i'm glad to hear you
say it once you get the vaccine how long
does it last
the answer to that is we just don't know
so it lasts at least six months and when
we look at the antibody levels and the t
cell levels
it's going to be at least a year at some
point you're going to need
probably a booster whether that be a one
year two year three years we don't know
yet
but it's going to give us protection in
the short run which is what we care
about
all right david agus thank you very much
you've given us some good information
there thanks good to see you always